Speaker 1: . I have a voicemail number you can
call any time. 2192. David P Here is
a caller who is again confused about
whether or not I am a socialist. Listen to this.
Speaker 5: If you just misspeak, I thought I just
heard you say that you are a social Democrat,
right? You mean to say you are a democratic
socialist? No. Would that be more accurate?
Speaker 1: No. No, I didn't misspeak,
sir. I am not a democratic socialist.
Democratic socialism is a form of socialism.
I am a social Democrat, which is a well-regulated
form of capitalism. I did not misspeak. I am not
a socialist. Some on the right and even some on
the left think I am a socialist, but I'm not.
I'm not criticizing socialism in this segment. I'm
just saying I'm not socialist. It's sort of like
if you say, David. Didn't you say you were black?
And I would go, No, I didn't say I was black. I'm
not black. Oh, so you don't like black people? No,
I'm I'm not saying that. I'm just saying I happen
not to be black. That's all I'm saying. I'm not
a socialist. Please. Okay. We have a great bonus
show for you today. We are going to talk about
the apoplectic reaction to Rihanna's Super Bowl
performance. We are going to talk about lawmakers
or as Donald Trump once called them, LA markers
focusing in on chat tea in the in this growing
popularity for the tool. And we are going to talk
about a bill from Bernie Sanders to boost Social
Security benefits not cut but rather boost. All of
those stories and more are on the bonus show.
Speaker 3: Thank you. Your lucky stars
every day you're not Dave Pacman.
Speaker 1: Well, I get to host the
bonus show. Alex so that's an exciting thing.
Sign up It joined PACs income I received.